there's a belief that philosophy when
properly done should sound dense
forbidding a little confusing as if it
might have been awkwardly translated
from the German but at the dawn of the
modern age lived a French philosopher
who trusted in a very different way of
presenting his thoughts a man who wrote
a very slim book barely sixty pages long
that can deservedly be counted as one of
the true masterpieces of philosophy the
book is a compendium of acerbic
melancholy observations about the human
condition each of them only a sentence
or two long which nevertheless present
an exceptional number of timely wise and
oddly consoling lessons for are morally
confused and wildly distracted age the
Duke de la Hache Foucault was born in
Paris in 1613 and despite as many
initial advantages wealth connections
good looks and a very beautiful and
ancient name
he had a thoroughly difficult and often
miserable life he fell in love with a
couple of duchesses who didn't treat him
well he ended up in prison after some
bungled but honourable political
maneuvering he was forced into exile
from his beloved Paris on four occasions
he never advanced as far as he wanted at
court he got shot in the eye during a
rebellion and almost went blind he lost
most of his money and some enemies
published what they falsely purported to
be as memoirs full of insults against
people whom he liked and depended upon
who then turned against him and refused
to believe in his innocence
after all this betrayal imprisonment
impoverishment injury plagiarism and
libel rush Foucault can readily be
forgiven when he declared that he'd had
enough of the act of life and would
henceforth retreat to quieter
contemplative pursuits instead so he
hung up his sword and spent his time in
the living rooms of two leading
intellectual figures of his day the
Marquis de subway and the contest Aleph
I yet
who regularly invited right as an artist
to sit with them in their Parisian
salons in order to discuss the great
themes of existence often over lemonade
and light snacks the salons rewarded wit
and spark
they weren't lecture halls or seminar
rooms there was no tolerance for lead
nurse or pomposity here so winning over
listeners required particular skills
that came to shape La Rochefoucauld mind
and work
it was in the salons that LaRoche buco
developed the literary Jean for which he
has become known that of the maxim or
aphorism a pithy statement that deftly
captures a dark insight into the human
soul reminding us of a wise and often
uncomfortable truth in good hands an
aphorism should deliver its punch in
less than three seconds
one might be competing with the arrival
of an asparagus tart in the salons La
Rochefoucauld perfected and honed the
500 for aphorisms which made his name he
watched out his fellow guests reacted
and tweaked his work accordingly his
aphorisms covered all manner of
psychological topics though issues of
envy vanity love and ambition were
recurring themes a typical la
rochefoucauld aphorism begins by
addressing the reader with a we or one
inviting consent with gentle coercion
the aphorism then subverts an accepted
piety about human nature in a cynical or
skeptical direction it's in the last
third of the sentence that the sting is
generally delivered and it often makes
us laugh as can happen when we're forced
to acknowledge the falsity of a
previously sentimental or hypocritical
position perhaps the most classic and
perfect of all Irish workers aphorism is
we all have strength enough to bear the
misfortunes of others it's closely
followed by the equally effective there
are some people who would never have
fallen in love if they hadn't heard
there was such a thing and the no less
accomplished he that refuses praise the
first time it's offered does it because
he would like to hear it a second
Voltaire said that LaRoche Rico's
Maxim's was the book that had most
powerfully shaped the character of the
French people giving them their taste
for psychological reflection precision
and cynicism behind almost every one of
the Maxim lies a challenge to an
ordinary flattering view of ourselves La
Rochefoucauld relishes revelations of
the debt that kindness owes to egoism
and insists that we're never far from
being vain arrogant selfish and petty
and in fact never nearer than when we
trust in our own goodness
having suffered unduly in its name
LaRoche Rico was particularly suspicious
of romantic love the reasons lovers
never tire of one another's company is
because they never talk of anything but
themselves if one were to judge of love
according
the greatest part of the effects it
produces it might very justly pass for
hatred rather than kindness to say that
one never flirts is in itself a form of
flirtation La Rochefoucauld wrote as he
did because he wanted his ideas to
persuade people whom he knew had little
time and wouldn't necessarily be on his
side if most philosopher sins have with
the odd exception felt no need to write
with his elegance wit and concision it's
because they've trusted wrongly that so
long as one's ideas are important the
style in which one delivers them is of
no issue La Rochefoucauld
knew otherwise most of us are so
distracted if someone wants to get a
point across to us they must use all the
devices of art and writing to see their
attention and burn them into our
memories the history of philosophy would
have been so different if its
practitioners had all imagined
themselves to be writing for an
impatient non-professional audience with
meandering Minds in the midst of a
chatty Parisian salon but history offers
us a new chance 140 characters of our
own digital salons now offer us a second
chance to try to put La Rochefoucauld
genius into action
you